[Music]
singing on a stage in front of thousands
of employees alibaba's Jack Ma is not
your average corporate chairman he
flunked his college entrance exam twice
that may have been the last time Jack Ma
set out to do something and failed this
readers ma is 49 years old and was
trained as an English teacher he learned
the language by working as a tour guide
and listening to Voice of America since
then he started one of China's first
Internet companies later ma persuaded 80
people to give him $60,000 and that was
the beginning of what is now the Alibaba
Group Alibaba is known for e-commerce
both consumer and business to business
but ma has broadened the company's
interests Alibaba is involved in cloud
computing banking TV production and even
has an online music service Maz personal
fortune is valued around thirteen
billion dollars still money doesn't seem
to be his motivation but building an
empire is ma told Charlie Rose if
Alibaba cannot surpass a Microsoft or
Walmart he will regret it for the rest
of his life
[Music]